The work of stellar archaeology really
goes to the heart of the,
we are star dust.
Um,
when we are children off the stars
statement,
you've probably heard it all,
but what does it actually mean?
We are mostly made all humans and all
life forms that,
that we know off made mostly of carbon
and bunch of other elements,
but in much lesser quantities.
Where does this carbon come from?
Well,
are,
you could say it comes from the earth
and yes,
that is true,
but how did it get into the earth?
Right?
And so that is where astronomy comes in
because there are multiple so-called
nucleo synthesis processes that creates,
um,
elements,
heavy elements.
They are fused lighter ones into heavier
ones,
starting with hydrogen for four hydrogen
atoms come together and fuse into a
helium atom and a few throw helium,
three helium atoms together.
You get a carbon nucleus and a,
this is how carbon is created and we
are,
um,
establishing how much carbon was created
at various times in the universe and
through which processes and through
which,
and in which types of stars.
And,
uh,
in what evolutionaries,
um,
phases of the stars.
This all happens.
And so this is how we can piece together
the chemical evolution of the universe
that is really the basis for any
biological evolution to take place on
earth.
And,
um,
I find it really exciting to,
to go back and really look at the,
at the constituents of life separately.
And we have studied not just carbon but
also nitrogen and phosphorous and sulfur
and oxygen and iron and all the
different elements,
um,
through our work and sell archeology.
And actually if you come to think about
it,
the Wa,
uh,
the,
the body is not just made of carbon but
also a lot of water and there is
hydrogen and oxygen in the water.
And a while we know oxygen also comes
from the stars.
You add another helium nucleus to a
carbon nucleus and you get an oxygen
nucleus.
But the water,
uh,
the,
the hydrogen protons,
they were all formed in the big bang.
So we actually carry about 10% of our
body weight,
um,
in,
in us that that is big bang material.
The protons were all recycle up numerous
times throughout the stars.
Um,
but the actual protons were made in the
hot,
Big Bang when all the subatomic
particles actually came together and
formed protons and neutrons.
And so that we are,
we are not just children off the stars.
Actually,
we are also children off of the Big Bang
and think it's really nice once in a
while too,
to reflect on that and,
and really realize how much we are
actually connected to the cosmos.